una decena de aldeas Palestina sufrieron
anoche violentas agresiones de colonos
israelíes que atacaron a personas y
propiedades horas después de que cuatro
israelíes murieran en un ataque armado
en el área de ramala según las
autoridades locales en el norte de
sijordania 34 palestinos resultaron
heridos Y al menos 140 vehículos se
fueron incendiados por turbas de colonos
que irrumpieron en jugar y otros
poblados cercanos arrojando piedras
incendiando automóviles Campos y
viviendas el incendio más grande se
registró el lugar al charquiya cerca del
asentamiento de ilai de donde procedían
dos de los colonos asesinados en el
ataque de ayer sin embargo tan solo tres
personas se fueron detenidas por estos
ataques si en cambio hubo marchas hacia
el asentamiento de gitsar y al puesto
ilegal de eviatar con demandas al
gobierno israelí de ejecutar una gran
operación militar en cisjordania y
autorizar una expansión todavía mayor de
las colonias que son consideradas
ilegales bajo el derecho internacional
por pronto el ejército israelí tomó las
medidas para demoler las viviendas de
los dos atacantes palestinos que eran
miembros del grupo jamás y que murieron
tras perpetrar en ataque contra un
restaurante y una gasolinera además el
Ministerio de defensa israelí ordenó
revocar los permisos de ingreso a
territorio israelí de decenas de sus
familiares ambas medidas que son
adoptadas a menudo por Israel también
son criticadas por organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos que las consideran un
castigo colectivo este último repunte de
violencia en Jordania inició el lunes
con una redada de israelía a gran escala
en cherín que hoy sumó una séptima
fallecida una joven de 15 años que había
recibido un disparo en la cabeza con
todos Ya son 136 los palestinos muertos
por fuego israelíense y Jordania ocupada
en 2023 la cifra más alta desde la
segunda intifada mientras que 25
personas murieron del lado israelí en
ataques palestinos